I'd be lying if I said I wasn't a little
nervous to write this video in 2020 I
reviewed eight-year odo's Magnum Opus
One Piece in 2021 I reviewed Musashi
kishimoto's Mega hit Naruto and I think
finally the time has come for me to
finish what I started you see during the
2000s alongside one piece and Naruto
there stood a third pillar within Shonen
Jump another edgy and now widely
controversial series called bleach
written by the amazingly talented Tite
Kubo bleach is a wickedly popular series
and to this day retains an enormous and
dedicated fan base the likes of which
would intimidate any online critic
myself included and initially I had
thought I would avoid writing a review
for this series altogether I've seen
what's happened to others in the past
that have spoken ill of this series and
I just didn't feel like poking the ball
however I have received thousands and I
mean thousands of comments over the last
few months asking pleading begging
screaming clambering jostling in that
order for me to review and cover their
favorite story bleach so I guess it's
time to finish the big three simple
right well you might say I have
something of a rocky relationship with
this series you see about 10 years ago
some friends and I got together to watch
from the very beginning bleach but for
one reason or another it didn't click
with me and I did make it very far
through the series before I just stopped
watching and I got on with my life
unfortunately for me however I made the
grave mistake of sharing that
information on Twitter a couple of years
ago which introduced me to some of
bleach's less than Savory online fans it
wasn't pretty and needless to say gave
me plenty of incentive to cut my losses
and cover something else but as the
title already has told you this is a
review so why did I decide to give it
another shot well there are a few
reasons firstly I enjoy reading manga
much more than watching anime I know
some folks think I'm crazy for willfully
missing out on the music voice acting
and the cool animations but I honestly
much prefer reading manga so much so
that the comparison it's not even close
for me I mean like seven years ago I
watched the JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
anime with another friend and I didn't
like it like at all but when that manga
was put in my face I couldn't put it
down and now I'm a huge fan of the
series secondly since my time having
watched bleach 10 years ago I've dropped
out of college had numerous jobs learned
a lot about narrative Theory and started
my own YouTube business so it's entirely
possible I'll see something in the story
I otherwise never would have before and
finally reason number three in April of
2022 my dear friend and member of the
team AJ took stock of the suggestions
you guys had been sending me under a
particular post bleach was the winner by
a country mile and so began my
deliberation over whether or not I
should review this series for me it was
a tough choice not because I didn't have
an interest in checking out this story
with a fresh perspective but more so
because everyone loves the guy that
Praises their favorite show but bleach
in particular seems to have a loud vocal
minority that isn't as forgiving to
those that share dissenting opinions on
this series they love however the anime
is returning and over the years I've
helped people find and fall in love with
series they wouldn't have given a chance
to before one piece is such an example
of this so what better time is there to
start helping build up the hype and
Community surrounding this cultural
Touchstone of a series than with a
review series that builds up to that
anime's eventual return this Autumn so
far I've loved one piece and Naruto and
with that knowledge I'm going into this
with an open mind as a different person
and honestly I'm really excited to see
what this Series has to show for itself
how does it measure up to the others
what makes it so special to so many and
will I like it this time around only one
way to find out it's time for my journey
to complete the big three by diving into
substitute Shinigami the premier Arc of
the prolific and massively popular work
by TJ Kubo everyone it's finally time
time to start our journey through bleach
substitute Shinigami is an interesting
Arc to say the least most arcs and
storytelling that I've come across and
certainly within the likes of Naruto in
one piece generally tell one long
cohesive story with an easily
identifiable somewhat traditional
beginning middle and end and while
substitute Shinigami offers its own
beginning middle and end it does so in a
structure reminiscent of an anthology
series or at least an episodic one with
each story connected in a unified effort
to depict the origin of her main
character Ichigo Kurosaki as he deals
with the tribulations that come from
this newfound responsibility thrust upon
him as a soul Reaper an entity whose job
it is to hunt down Hollows and send them
either to Soul Society if they've been
good or to hell if they've been bad
episodic stories often times in the past
have run for me the risk of feeling
exceedingly formulaic with an
over-reliance on a familiar structure to
fall back on and while there is a vague
element of that here I actually really
liked this like a lot and this really
surprised me by just how much I enjoy
myself while reading reading this manga
was like an entirely different
experience characters that I had found
deeply and profoundly irritating in the
anime now either played much smaller
roles or straight up weren't there
action that I found tired or
uninteresting suddenly felt Dynamic and
flowed perfectly into kubo's magnificent
layouts and okay the artwork oh my good
Lord in heaven I am in heaven I finally
found a manga that feels like it's
taking cues from Dragon Ball and built a
planet and you have no idea how excited
that makes me so in order to get all of
my thoughts out on this Arc and I do
have a lot of thoughts I've decided to
split this review up into segments with
each segment relating to a particular
cluster of chapters in this Arc that
tell their own story we'll go through
these in order so let's start with
bleach's beginning and ichigo's origin
despite having a much much higher
opinion of bleach after having finished
this Arc I gotta say the first chapter
of this series was probably its weakest
part by a wide margin not necessarily
because because there was anything
egregious in its construction but more
so due to how uninspired and clunky some
of it felt both visually and narratively
let me show you what I mean the chapter
opens with Ichigo reprimanding a group
of nerdwells who've knocked down an
offering made to a young child that
might have recently passed away this
scene serves a multitude of functions it
reveals to us who Ichigo is what he
stands for what he looks like and his
overall personality in addition to that
we also learn a bit about what he can do
he can see and speak to ghosts the
dialogue is okay maybe a little simple
but it does the job visually however I
found this opening scene to be lacking
in basic Clarity and I don't mean that
to be condescending I mean that I don't
think the pages communicated what they
needed to for the scene to work or at
the very least as effectively as it
otherwise could have been the only
establishing shots we get are a close-up
of one down skateboarder and a mid shot
of three people standing in a Parkway
all three members in that panel look
angry and at first I thought those two
standing behind Ichigo were his friends
but as it happened they aren't these are
two of the I think five or so thugs in
this scene it's honestly difficult to
tell without a wider shot to establish
what Ichigo is up against the panels
feel claustrophobic and without that
context or greater understanding we
can't fully appreciate how Ichigo stood
up against the group for the benefit of
a young deceased spirit with that said
the scene does still achieve this to
some extent but not as well as it
otherwise could have this becomes
massively apparent when Tite Kubo really
starts to show what he's capable of in
later chapters and even in this one's
conclusion so let's talk dialogue as
Ichigo arrives home we get bombarded
with three new characters all with
distinct personalities we meet ichigo's
eccentric and aggressive father and his
two younger sisters the quiet inclined
Yuzu and the more edgy Karen all seems
perfectly standard until the plot comes
floating into ichigo's room this is
Rukia and Rukia offers us the perfect
chance to talk about the difference
between natural and unnatural Exposition
as she plays a role in facilitating both
in the this long introductory chapter
Rukia is something in this world called
a soul Reaper a soul Reaper's job is to
cleanse this world of entities known as
Hollows and holes sending them somewhere
called The Soul Society holes are the
good ghosts Ichigo routinely has seen
and Hollows are evil trouble spirits
that have turned into monsters of
varying hulking size and ability I know
all of this not because it was shown to
me but because Rukia told us this and
look Exposition like this sometimes is
needed but this feels at odds with the
scene itself Rukia the soul Reaper is on
the scene to cleanse it of a dangerous
evil spirit but for some reason she
feels comfortable enough to explain
herself and the inner workings offer
profession to Ichigo in detail despite
it being on the loose and having lost
track of it suddenly in a residential
area tide Kubo must have been aware of
this because there's a panel where even
Ichigo asks her to at one point quit her
yammering the purpose of this scene is
to explain the world of bleach for sure
but it's also trying to assert that
Hollows are dangerous and evil spirits
and because of her dedication to
explaining this to Ichigo someone that
doesn't need to know this I think this
unfortunately ends up sending mixed
signals is this important or is it not
however to be fair she also facilitates
some natural means of exposition too she
helps us to learn how special Ichigo
truly is upon arriving on the scene in
pursuit of this hollow she's
consistently Blown Away by how Ichigo
can see her break free from her spells
and eventually confuses her senses all
of this is shown to us before it's
explained and as it happens all of these
were indications that Ichigo was not
only the reason why she lost track of
the hollow in the first place but why
the hollow was there at all to Feast on
his vast amounts of spirit energy and
that's great conveyance it makes sense
within the world gives Ichigo a reason
to fight any believable and natural
means for him to fight this monster and
that's not even the best part of this
chapter not by a long shot because I
think I found my spiritual successor to
Akira toriyama's philosophy when it
comes to action paneling we only get a
flavor a fleeting taste of it in this
chapter both the dynamic angles
implemented the utilization of force
perspective the strong gestural drawings
and the use of minimalistic backgrounds
all helped to deliver some terrific
action sequences that are a joy to
follow as the following chapters flow on
by key differences emerge that set this
story apart from the likes of one piece
and Naruto but perhaps more
interestingly is how each go himself is
characterized unlike Luffy and Naruto
two bombastic and optimistic outcasts
Ichigo isn't your stereotypical Shonen
Jump good boy he's definitely got his
virtues for sure but an excuse this
comparison on the scale of midoriya to
bakugou he seems much closer to Papago
than before you can really see that
mid-2000s Ang seeped through these Pages
which brings me to one of my absolute
favorite aspects of this story something
to help us appreciate specific
characters all the more at the end of
each and every volume Tite Kubo draws
two special info blurbs for us to read
concerning two characters of his choice
there's information on their blood type
birthday what their interests are what
they eat et cetera Etc standard stuff
but at the very end he provides
something else
music the manga has music okay well sort
of Tita Kubo offers something I've never
before come across in other forms of
manga quite ingeniously he attributes a
theme song to his characters to help
communicate their overall vibe to the
audience and in the process share some
really interesting and fun music I
personally would never have otherwise
discovered I've written reviews for
years now and when a series offers me a
chance to talk about something unique
like this I have to examine it and on
top of all of this it serves the story
by giving us a more accurate
interpretation of the characters
involved so let's take a look at
ichigo's theme
ichigo's theme is news from the front by
Bad Religion and the song's composition
mimics the characterization of Ichigo
himself perfectly I think there's no
Preamble no easing ourselves into the
track with a gentle instrumentation much
like Ichigo himself this song does not
beat around the bush it gets right into
the quick Tempo Rock and drum beats that
color much of its composition
immediately like this song Ichigo
doesn't pretend to be anything he isn't
in an effort to appease others
furthermore the track is remarkably
melodic perhaps symbolizing that behind
the grit and harshness of the guitarist
lies something much more refined Guided
by a simple structure a method that
controls the madness exactly like each
Goku while he might appear on carrying
he isn't in his own words a scumbag and
is willing to do the right thing if
given the choice in other words just
like this song despite it being
obstructed by Otherwise gritty
instrumentation and personality there is
a heart behind it both of these artistic
musings are the perfect blend of tough
and thoughtful that beg for both a
memorable and likable character as well
as a song you'll be humming along to no
matter your taste in music
today's video is brought to you by our
longtime Partners over at manscape.com
they've been great supporters of this
channel for a while now and I've spoken
at length about their performance
package bundle in the past it really is
the best head to toe grooming kit I've
encountered and their lawnmower 4.0 is
the star of the package with its
wonderful LED light and skin safe Tech
the crop preserver ball deodorant is
also a pretty great part of the package
particularly in these hot months where
keeping cool and smelling great all day
is pretty damn important but what's also
essential is the follow through manscape
have released a new collection of their
anti-chafing high performance boxer
briefs these bad boys feature a fancy
new Jewel pouch design a good old bit of
roomy space for your dangly bits to
breathe thanks to the perforated
performance fabric they're also now in
more than six colors combined there's a
simple all black pack or The Classy gray
or pinstripe design heck there's even
this gold nugget craziness if you want
to go all out it's entirely up to you I
mean I'm not your mom whatever you
choose manscape offers the option to
select single units or save money with
their three pack options they're great
and if you go to manscape.com today and
use coupon code not Mark 20 at checkout
you'll get 20 off plus free
international shipping that's not Mark
20 at manscape.com your balls ooh thank
you
for life's bleachable moments
Orihime and her brother by the time
chapter 2 arrived pretty much all the
shortcomings I mentioned from the first
chapter had vanished dialogue was quirky
and flowed nicely as did the layouts and
panel structure there were establishing
shots implemented and the artwork only
got better and better there's definitely
an element of Chosen One energy
sprouting from the opening chapter that
perforates into the second and at first
that concerned me a little I've never
been one that got too interested in
themes of Fate but I will say that I
like that the driving force isn't
ichigo's in a chosen Oneness but instead
Rookie's desire to get her powers back
from Ichigo and due to this unique set
of circumstances it creates a moral
obligation for Ichigo to carry the
mantle as Soul Reaper until such time
she gets these powers back or until
Ichigo sees the need to retain those
Powers I don't know how this is going to
continue I honestly can't remember and
it's a great setup that Segways
perfectly into the first short story of
this greater Arc and it concerns orehime
I honestly can't remember if there's an
enormous difference in how the anime
depicts this character but I found
Orihime to be much more likable and
compelling this time around with the
manga I love her dorky kind-hearted
nature acting as either the Catalyst or
the driving force behind a number of
effective comedic moments with Kubo
effectively utilizing Chibi characters
to create greater contrast in moments of
comedy with his more edgy character
types and overly exaggerated reaction
shots to help sell the insanity however
for me
instincts when it comes to creating
exceptionally strong action layouts and
Page turns that reach out and grab your
attention like few I've seen before for
example in chapter 3 page 16 rookie
exclaims to get ichigo's attention the
panel takes up a nice third of the page
following that there's a smaller panel
showing ichigo's reaction as well as the
payoff to a pajama gag set up earlier in
the chapter and following that there's
an even smaller panel that makes you
lean in to ask an important question
where is the hollow coming from and then
boom the next page explodes with that
very answer it's a basic but effective
structure and you'd be shocked at how
some of the most famous manga don't make
use of these more foundational
principles more often the delivery is
formatted well sets up the next page
perfectly and begs us to keep reading
and this is partially why I prefer
reading manga while anime has other
attributes that offer a unique and
wonderful experience for people to enjoy
it can do this quite as effectively and
it's when an author chooses to do this
that gives me a glimpse into how they
work and how they're thinking that I
otherwise wouldn't appreciate or receive
if I was watching the anime which
regardless of the faithfulness of the
adaptation is still only an
interpretation of the original work at
the end of the day so leave me alone
with my picture books I like reading
manga I don't watch cartoons okay that's
a lie I do watch cartoons the short
story in question this time around has
its fair share of spectacular action too
however what made a standout amidst all
of these stories was how it managed to
effectively characterize Orihime for me
as I mentioned she's played for Laughs a
lot of the time but as the short story
trudges toward this darker conclusion so
too do we gain a different perspective
of the order he made character herself
the tail concerning orderhime explores
the themes of lost grievance and regret
as they exist within the world bleach
has constructed having lost her only
adult figure in her older brother when
she was little she's forced herself to
find the positives in life and to lead
the life she thought her brother would
want her to live however having left the
land of the living that very brother has
returned as a hollow having felt her
sister moving on has left him with
nothing this negativity consumed his
Spirit until he became a monster that
would do harm unto her and those like
Ichigo that would do anything to protect
her it's explained that when one becomes
a hollow they eat The Souls of their
family first which honestly could be
seen as a metaphor for regret and one's
inability to deal with grief and in the
same way Ichigo had his own theme song
that helped to express the vibe Kuba was
going for with his character so too did
he see fit to provide orohime with her
very own
[Music]
and upon hearing this while totally
appropriate and fitting for the
character it paints certainly much more
interesting light than what I recalled
from the anime it starts off slow with
an almost melancholic lonely piano line
which eventually gains the accompaniment
of an exceedingly soft and sweet voice
dancing angelically alongside this Sad
Piano before suddenly the track starts
to pick itself up with a drumline that
almost forces the rest of the
composition to pick up its Tempo it's
difficult to describe but I think the
emphasis this song puts on that sudden
tonal shift matches perfectly the young
sweet and harmless girl who lost
everything trying her best to live as
happy a life as she can the track itself
never quite manages to become as upbeat
as the others that I'll touch on in this
video but it more than tries its best
with vocals that sound like they are
forcing a tortured smile it's incredibly
fitting for the character who tried her
best to live a happy life for her
brother to watch upon from Heaven it's a
wonderful song and one that's honestly
given me a newfound appreciation for the
character
some very heavy and dark subject matter
to be dealing with particularly so early
on in this series there are plenty of
horror elements included in this like
jump scares grotesque imagery and
difficult subject matter for sure making
for the perfect setup for our hero the
bleach himself Ichigo to come in and
swing his big sword to save the day in
chapter 6 there's a terrific page turn
the fourth page is all set up the fifth
page hides what happens next in the
title page builds suspense and then jeez
page six is something else and it's so
easy to read and I think a lot of that
has to do with the use of white space in
the background of a lot of these panels
often times when a big page spread
appears there's very little in the
background to distract from the main
characters everything just pops that
little bit more than other stories I've
read lately and physically reminds me a
lot of how Akira Toriyama would panel
Dragon Ball he'd chalk it down to
laziness of course but it really did
help to communicate exactly where he
wanted my attention to be focused there
is a resolution found at the end of this
and it involves Orihime saving the day
by reaching her brother in his darkest
moment however while cathartic it's
bittersweet having passed on Happily and
at peace now both oruhime and her
brother get the closure they need with
her getting the opportunity to right the
wrong she's felt she committed by
finally getting to wish her brother a
nice day and not leaving their final
parting to an argument and the visuals
in the manga demonstrate this exact
Phenomenon with her spirit body being
dragged back into her living form thus
allowing her to move on and Sora her
brother exercised from his tortured
existence now at peace in the soul
Society following this they share a
tender moment and then her memory gets
erased by urukia that's sort of awful
sure Sora gets his closure and passes on
but Orihime doesn't and with how she
carries herself putting on a brave face
we might not ever know how the guilt
affects her moving forward it's an
interesting and sad ethical point that
this fantastic series of chapters has
ended on for sure to conclude this
otherwise tragic story yuichi the
parakeet from this point Don I'm going
to try to cover these stories a little
faster which is fitting as some of them
are actually quite short this story
Chronicles another rather dark subject a
young boy's Spirit has been put into a
parakeet and is being pursued by a
one-time serial killer now in Hollow
form through this story we get
introduced to the character of Chad
strong stoic gentle and Noble he's just
sort of one of those characters you like
almost immediately and now that he finds
himself as The Unofficial guardian of
this parakeet time it again increasingly
dangerous circumstances before this
gentle giant oh also something I really
liked about this Arc was a choice to
have Karin be the mechanism that sets up
our expectations for how monstrous this
hollow truly is as pointed out on a
number of instances in this story Karen
is spiritually sensitive and perceptive
like Ichigo but not exactly the same
however it is enough to discern what the
origin of this young parakeet truly is
and here's the best part we don't see
what she sees we just see her reaction
to the reality of the situation and
she's horrified we later find out in
greater detail what occurred but that
expression is what stayed with me long
after finishing this part of the story
it's like the Jaws principle show the
audience the shark and it's a little
underwhelming however hide the shark
from sight and suddenly our imagination
fills in the gaps to make the scene all
the more frightening in addition there
are also two fantastic fights to talk
about here however one just stole the
show for me while Ichigo has a
gorgeously depicted and Illustrated
fight to close out this section giving
it the closure and spectacle it deserves
it's Chad's fight alongside Rukia
combining their forces that Kubo clearly
had the most fun orchestrating I think
it has it all cool moments character
Rich dialogue and some genuinely
interesting and compelling choreography
with rookia providing Chad the means to
see the Target and Chad offering up his
strength to Rukia to overcome this
obstacle and honestly I thought it was
much needed and in addition to that
despite being outmashed in practically
every capacity Rukia still encouraged
Ichigo to take his little sister home to
safety prioritizing her safety knowing
full well she herself had insufficient
physicality for which to carry out this
very tall task in dealing with this
hollow it's a courageous and tenacious
moment for her character and it might be
my favorite moment from her thus far in
this series showcasing how resourceful
and effective she can be in a pinch even
when handicapped so massively and in
addition to that narratively her doing
so offers the opportunity for us to
learn the hollow's techniques in a
natural setting such that Ichigo himself
gets to enjoy the climax of the fight
free of any expository responsibilities
later on similarly to Ichigo tarukia
character has her own theme song granted
by Mr cupo himself too and despite her
possessing some similar qualities to
Ichigo their tracks are starkly
different fitting as they are both in
many respects Worlds Apart both
figuratively and personally the title of
her theme is wingstock by Ashley mcisac
foreign
unlike ichigo's no-nonsense Rock track
that for the time was rather modern
rukia's score is a little more
mysterious and utilizes elements and
instrumentation in its composition that
Harkens back to a forgotten past while
being rooted within a modern repurposing
of said instrumentation in other words
it uses folk music and infuses it with
more modern rock interpretations it
begins much like how she enters this
story alone a single enchanting piano
purposely guides us into the Trad Rock
folk Anthem diss track ultimately
becomes following soon after an excited
triumphant violin propels this chorus
forward without words and largely grants
this song A folks equality that each
goes much more grounded guitar track did
not similar to how the instrumentation
combines two genres Rock and traditional
folk music to create something entirely
new Rukia herself exemplifies an
individual from A Different World
repurposed in order to exist within
ichigos the absence of lyrics is also
somewhat noteworthy I think almost as if
to suggest torukia words aren't what's
important actions are stands to reason
as it's what Ichigo has chosen to act on
that has impressed Rukia the most in
this story unlike other tales that
possess themes for characters that were
inspired by the characters themselves
beforehand these very much feel like
characters written and inspired by
someone who was emotionally moved by for
one reason or another these very pieces
of music creating for us unique
characters with a sense of identity as
true and clear as the pieces they have
been inspired by potentially and to be
perfectly honest I don't consider myself
to be well-versed in music theory but
even I could glean this from this closer
look and listening meaning perhaps most
importantly this offers an opportunity
for most people to engage with a
character on a unique level that they
have perhaps never had the chance to do
so with in the past the story itself
ends with Ichigo proving that he's the
Giga Chad we all need in Shonen by
taking out this serial killer Hollow
allowing the boy to go to Soul Society
to reunite with his mother and onwards
we March to the next weird and wild
story in this Arc fake Ichigo this is a
short four chapter long story that deals
with the introduction of a new mechanic
in this world of bleach while
simultaneously introducing a brand new
character this is Khan say hi Khan the
tone of this short story is
significantly lighter and more Slice of
Life compared to the other installments
thus far there are no psychological
torments that need to be overcome
through reconciliation with a lost loved
one there's no serial killers Instead
This one kicks off with Rukia purchasing
some sort of Soul pill dispenser to
allow Ichigo the ability to go Soul
Reaper mode on his own without her help
she buys it from this dude called Mr
Kiss k he becomes important later and
initially we think this works like a
charm he's able to transform into a soul
we perform and no longer does he have to
worry about his unconscious corpse being
carried off somewhere or lost because
now it's inhabited by some sentient
being supplied for this purpose through
the soul Society also we think there's a
big problem though it sort of has full
autonomy and desires of its own so I
guess it's faulty while there are indeed
Hollow battles in this story the focus
isn't really on that but instead the
conundrum that they are now faced with
when the soul inside ichigo's body isn't
all that bad proving that to them by
Khan himself making the save against
this hollow they fight ultimately he
stops running and helps Ichigo take down
the hollow before explaining that he
can't bring himself to so much as kill a
bug that every life to him is precious
and Upon finishing thy thought Mr kiss
gay arrives in the scene sucks the soul
out of ichigo's body leaving the corpse
fall lifelessly to the ground thankfully
however Rukia swipes his soul back from
Mr kuskey and injects it into a stuffed
lion dub however we're left to ponder
the really dark Revelation we've just
experienced similarly to what happened
to orokime with the memory Erasure this
is another example of the Soul Society
not necessarily being the Arbiters of
all that is good in the universe either
making for a much more complicated story
not simply good versus evil June 17th
titled the 17th of June this date marks
the anniversary that ichigo's mother
died a day that both he and his family
take off every year to visit her grave
and spend time together thinking of her
this is a welcomed albeit's surprising
shift in tone from previous stories but
offered perhaps the best peek into the
past and youth of the main character
himself Ichigo particularly when he
mentions that he was the reason why she
died to Rukia upon inquiry as a kid
Ichigo would always smile when he was
with or saw his mother Ichigo as a child
wanted to get stronger to protect those
that needed protecting he wanted to
learn how to fight for that very reason
putting himself through tough times to
become tough himself however on one dark
and wet day he saw someone standing over
the river someone looking like they were
going to jump he runs to save them his
mom follows and
foreign
[Music]
that is such a difficult sentiment to
have to live with thinking that you were
responsible for trying to save people
and through doing so ended up leading to
your own mother's death
something I haven't really touched on in
this video yet has been the designs of
the hollows and the significant ways
they have all differed thus far there's
something of a philosophy behind their
construction certainly however they do
all still differ in significant ways
that speak to either their true nature
or personality in this case it's both
fire Hollows we've stumbled and sliced
through in the past have varied from
basic to torture to psychotic with the
one we Tangled with alongside yuichi the
parakeet being the most despicable and
notorious of the bunch notorious enough
for rookia to make a purchase from Mr
kuske anyway that was because he had
become a problem taking the life of
other Soul Reapers he was at large and
dangerous for months if not years this
one however this hollow we're dealing
with right here has been in the loose
for 54 years designed sort of like an
anglerfish it meshes nicely with the
tragic deceptive and cruel means with
which it lures its victims in preying on
their honest and virtuous intentions to
help those that the victims perceive as
being in need it's the very quality that
lured Ichigo as a child into its
clutches and ultimately what led to his
mother's death the running theme of this
fight is that Ichigo is being too
Reckless too inexperienced to tackle
something this monstrous and it's toying
with him depicting his mother before him
acting as its new lure knowing full well
how it will make Ichigo feel and lash
out during this tussle of rookia
grapples with what she ought to do value
the preservation of ichigo's Life by
helping him in this mismatch or preserve
his honor by staying out of it like he
requested Ichigo takes a massive blow
but thankfully in doing so manages to
land his own substantial attack against
this much more advanced adversary the
Huddle fled Ichigo fought to his limit
before collapsing and he kept his
promise to Rukia he did not die talk
about an intense conclusion to the story
easily the best and most emotionally
resonant of the series so far and not
just for the battle but for what happens
after the conflict finally to cap off my
thoughts on this chunk of story chapter
25 has a fantastically emotional scene
that doesn't Bend or betray any of the
characters involved it's a quiet scene
Ichigo shares with his father and look I
won't lie when I was watching the anime
10 years ago ichigo's father was one of
the characters I connected with the
least I found him to be very loud
obnoxious and overall quite annoying
however despite in the manga him still
being quite over the top I rarely see
him as much so when I saw him walk up
alongside Ichigo in front of his mom's
grave I was genuinely excited to see the
interaction they'd share and I wasn't
disappointed it felt so natural and sad
with tinges of old-fashioned advice the
scene doesn't try to make his character
more dramatic than he otherwise would
feel naturally there's plenty of
slapstick and he's upbeat as normal but
what makes the scene special was his
willingness to share that moment with
Ichigo and to explain why he feels how
he feels and does what he does with his
final message to Ichigo being stop
sulking you're not old enough for the
cool tortured look I'll see you down the
hill encouraging him to not waste his
youth torturing himself that life is
Tough Enough on its own without you
adding to that problem and that while
Ichigo had has time on his side he
should spend it laughing and living life
to the full before as he says he too
meets his father down that Hill perhaps
metaphorically implying that one day
life might throw Ichigo another
curveball and when such a time might
occur as a chance that then he could
lack the time to overcome it these are
similar sentiments echoed in the theme
song provided by Kubo for this very
character entitled don't drag me down by
Social Distortion this track would be
one of the last songs this band would
release during their final mainstream
run and as a complete unit together
since 1978 in the year 2000 shortly
before the Inception of this story the
guitarist of the band Dennis Daniel
dropped dead of an aneurysm tragic in
every sense of the word and another
reminder of just how fleeting life could
be the song itself offers a much harder
Rock sound than that of the previous
blues and rockabilly sounds that colored
much of their earlier work again echoing
the message ichigo's Father offers him
that there's plenty of time to be hard
on yourself later in life and that one
shouldn't waste their time sulking their
life away it's a fascinating chariotop
this stunningly beautiful and well
orchestrated scene
quickly because I don't really have that
much to say I liked it but you know not
very long and well not much to say the
purpose behind this short story is to
achieve three things narratively as far
as I could notice number one explain to
us what Demi Hollows are and how Hollows
come to be number two show that Ichigo
is a pretty altruistic hero and number
three perhaps the most interesting lay
the groundwork for a reveal that will
occur later through ichigo's friends
being a lot more perceptive than they
have let on in the past except Chad Chad
could send something before we like Chad
alright so there's this new spiritualist
on TV almost everyone is a fan of this
guy in ichigo's circles except for him
naturally and this dude is coming to
town to film his special people are
understandably excited more broadly
speaking this story focuses on a more
comedic nature with much of its humor
being derived from how we understand
Ichigo wouldn't have time for this sort
of activity he sulks quite a lot of this
also I kind of like this approach Kubo
is taking here it's low stakes but
because what's happening is leveraging a
true aspect of his character were
invested or at the very least
entertained by the comedy sort of in the
same same way Vegeta might act when
doing something silly for beerus or whis
we all know he's a no-nonsense guy being
forced to participate or endure nonsense
and this situation with Ichigo is very
similar additionally sometimes when I'm
reviewing manga I get a little jaded
reviewing content is my job and due to
that I have to pick up my hobby when I'm
not in the mood too often times but
bleach is so different to Naruto in one
piece that for me right now it honestly
feels really fresh there are of course
integral plot lines to follow throughout
this Arc however I can relax much of the
time and enjoy short stories like this
one with panels that legitimately make
me laugh at the festival this is where
everyone from Chad tatsuki Orihime Karen
and naturally Ichigo can hear the Demi
Hollow the idea of a demi Hollow
explores what the process of becoming a
hollow looks like those who hold on to
regrets are literally anchored to the
regret in the mortal world by the chain
of Fate unable to pass on to the soul
Society if their regret stems from a
person they are possessed by tsuki
Spirits if it stems from a place they
become something called called jibaku so
that's kind of interesting Mr kananji
the spiritualist guy provokes the Demi
Hollow into becoming a full-blown Hollow
inadvertently and the transformation
into that Hollow is depicted brilliantly
in the manga haunting looking like the
very Humanity that made this man who he
was being quite literally enveloped and
devoured by his hollow form itself in
essence his regret literally consumes
him there's a cool battle that takes
place but ultimately Ichigo defeats the
hollow and explains to kanunji his own
personal failings in response kanunji
recognizes his mistake and admires
Ichigo calling him a hero alright next
up a big story The quincies standing at
roughly 18 chapters in length this is
the longest stretch of consistent story
bleachers yet thrown away and it
explores quite a lot so buckle up
roughly speaking this section is
structured around a specific
confrontation between Ichigo and some
mysterious man that keeps killing the
hollows before Rukia and Ichigo get the
chance to cleanse those spirits and
lately every time Ichigo arrives in the
scene the hollow he's chased after is
gone who could this mystery man be
jinkies
well okay it's not really a mystery as
the entire point of this character is to
tell us exactly who he is and what his
relation to or interest in Ichigo is
this is uru Ishida and he's something
known as a Quincy and let me tell you he
hates Soul Reapers but he's got a really
sweet energy bow and arrow so All Is
Forgiven my sweet prince he eventually
goes on to explain that the Quincy's
were once a clan dedicated to killing
Hollows all over the world however 200
years ago they all perished as a Quincy
Urdu believes that Hollow should be
killed end of story while Soul Reapers
on the other hand believe that they
should instead be cleansed this could
potentially be an interesting
philosophical discussion in this story
one that contends with capital
punishment and the ethics of it what
should Justice be is it revenge is it
Erasure or should one be given the
chance to atone and live out its days
naturally the comparison isn't totally
analogous to ours for obvious reasons
but there are some similarities the
hollow creatures could be used in this
instance as a metaphor for unforgivable
behavior these Spawn from regret and
Powerful negative emotions and once in
that form the person behind it entirely
loses themselves to that evil spirit
becoming monsters this is in many ways
similar to how some people view
prisoners in the correction system do we
believe that the person within is worth
rehabilitating worth giving a second
chance like the soul Society offers or
are we only looking out for ourselves in
this instance the quincies in this
instance are capital punishment while
Soul Reapers allow the judgment to be
cast by who that person is or was rather
than by themselves the conversations
however become a lot more complicated
beyond that with early reveals that the
Soul Reapers are often hours too slow to
take action and due to that leads to the
deaths of innocent lives so the Quincy
saw themselves as something of a quick
response team that could take action in
ways the Soul Reapers simply could not
however this created an imbalance which
led to the potential collapse of the
Universe I know things are getting a
little crazy now but they were asked to
stop and well they didn't so they fought
in all ultimately the quincies were
eradicated leaving this lone Quincy here
before us challenging this Soul Reaper
in Ichigo to a contest using Hollow bait
he begins attracted them to the city and
with that declares that the one
parameter of this contest is whoever
defeats the most Hollows in 24 hours
will be declared the winner something
you might notice as you read this manga
is just how fast Kubo gets better and
better as an illustrator and layout
artist there are moments in this manga
that truly remind me at least in spirit
of Akira toriyama's Dragon Ball and
anyone who's followed me through other
review series knows that I consider that
to be up there as some of the easiest
and most effective weekly manga to read
when it comes to page composition
despite being much more Slice of Life
Focus than Dragon Ball in this instance
kubo's approach to paneling illustration
and general posing always struck me as
interesting take this scene for example
from chapter 34. Ichigo is revealed to
be in the top 18 of his 322 strong class
it's just a conversation and yet kubo's
drawings are full of life here he could
have very easily gotten away with
Talking Heads but there's so much more
energy and dynamism in these drawings
that he's provided look at this
foreshortened pose of Ichigo cracking
his knuckles this is a difficult drawing
by All Things Considered and the scene
didn't need it to convey what I was
talking about but it absolutely benefits
from it this honestly reminds me of the
preamble to Goku's fight with Napa to
some specific degree Napa Troy is
desperately to hit Goku only for him to
miss every single time with the cherry
on top being this foreshortened image of
Goku standing atop Napa's head it didn't
need to be there but it heightens the
scene
in both of these instances this extra
mile these artists have gone to serve to
communicate the aloofness of both main
characters brilliantly all the while
making what could have been a collection
of rather boring scenes very interesting
at the very least to look at I want
manga to do more of this whether it's
cracking knuckles or fixing a teddy bear
with a sewing kit Kubo seems to have a
flare for the dramatic making the most
innocuous of activities thrilling to sit
read through its truly amazing work and
it's not just artwork Kubo proved that
he's proficient with the basics of
Storytelling too through reveals like
that which takes place with Orihime and
Chad both human characters established
as part of ichigo's schoolyard Posse
have also been foreshadowed on a number
of instances to be Spirit sensitive to
varying degrees manifesting an
incredibly fun scenes like Chad's team
up with Karen another great fight which
he totally steals the show in by the way
thanks to his Newfound improved arm and
of course the philosophical Mantra that
he lives by that strength is something
that he's been gifted with and so he
must learn to be kind and use that power
to protect those that cannot protect
themselves in this case ichigo's little
sister and of course we have Orihime
coming to the rescue of our friends at
the last moment with those strange but
funny new pixie friends it seems like
our powers are much more defense focused
so with that I'm also interested in
seeing how that plays into the future of
other battles in this series this is a
big deal and pretty much acts as a
signal to our two angry boys to stop
fighting each other and focus on finding
this larger threat and you know things
are getting serious because Mr kiss gay
this mysterious dude who's been lurking
in the background stunning them is now
taking action to help them there's a bit
of a back and forth that takes place
here some cute tag team attacks with
these two and of course more unreal
artwork from Kubo eventually Ichigo
explains that he can't control or Focus
his Spirit energy that it's like a
faucet on high with no means of turning
off the flow which isn't a problem
because
holy [ __ ] overall this section was a
solid piece of Storytelling with a
terrific main set piece to cap off a
mini Arc filled with a lot of lore and
history and to top it off this Arc does
something none of the other mini arcs
have done thus far where all of them had
clear-cut endings before starting
something entirely new afterwards this
one ends and flows naturally into the
main story of this entire Arc that being
the consequences of Rookie's actions as
it concerns the soul Society following
chapter 1. Rukia and the Soul Society
now that these bad boys are on our tail
vrukia elects to leave ichigo's place
and life leaving just a letter behind
and while this move narratively is a
little conventional nowadays I think
there's a lot one could find interesting
here also we've seen stories like this
before of course where one member of the
party goes it alone because they want to
protect the others but I think it's how
this one sets up the decision made by
Rukia and what it might be narratively
that I find the most fascinating if we
look back in the first chapter of the
series Karen ichigo's little sister made
it known that despite her abilities to
see spirits she would pretend they
didn't exist and thus absolved herself
of any responsibility in her mind in the
second chapter Ichigo and Rukia have a
conversation concerning that very
mindset one in which Rukia tries to
convince Ichigo to take the next step
and become a soul Reaper while she is
out of action in response Ichigo says
I'm not gonna fight those things for
total strangers I'm not that
self-sacrificing this actually doesn't
sit too well with Rukia who then take
Ichigo to a specific location a location
where if Ichigo does nothing a hollow
will attack a child and sure enough a
giant Hollow emerges and starts to
pursue a small young kid Rukia then says
but he's a complete stranger right are
you going to help him Ichigo replies are
you crazy I can't just stand here and
watch that thing eat him and then urukia
drops the final bombshell before your
eyes or out of sight they're going to be
attacked either way the purpose of this
scene is to illustrate the Spider-Man
principle that with great power comes
great responsibility that if you have
the power to help someone and you don't
help that person then the bad things
that come from it are due to your own
inaction entirely rejecting this out of
sight out of mind line of argumentation
they've been running with since chapter
one and now 50 chapters later Rukia
reintroduces this very theme once again
out of sight out of mind she does not
want to get attached to Ichigo and the
others because according to her that's
boring when in reality she doesn't want
to do it because it's too painful too
difficult or Ichigo didn't want to
accept the physical responsibilities of
becoming a soul Reaper the professional
aspect of it Rukia isn't considering her
own and others feelings when she chose
to leave without saying a single word
thinking only of Judy and her job she
says in chapter 52 If eventually I must
leave this place friendship and
affection will only make it difficult
none of them are necessary emotions for
a soul Reaper and so in the same way
chapter 2 demonstrated Ichigo rejecting
his spiritual side this chapter
demonstrates Rukia rejecting her Human
Side distancing herself in the process
putting herself in more danger not
understanding that all this will do is
drag Ichigo to her rescue in a much more
unsafe situation these guys have really
cool designs and I feel like as the
story trudges on things are only going
to get better in that department and I
just love love love that uriu the person
Ichigo went out of his way to befriend
the one who now represents friendship
and Humanity in this thematic Journey
comes to her rest well
um that's not good
[Music]
if you wanna see some action
now that's more like it I think my
favorite thing I've noticed about this
manga's characters is how it's playing
everything straight I feel like we live
in a time where because characters like
this were once a dime a dozen nowadays
there's a lot more emphasis on
undercutting characters that take action
and say things like this making them the
butt of jokes and sort of uncool and so
It's oddly refreshing just getting a
main character that isn't some dork that
can confidently arrive on the scene and
say something cool like this and it feel
natural admittedly I could change my
tone on this once the story trudges on
and it happens more and more but as of
right now you might as well call this
McDonald's because I'm loving it I I
absolutely regret saying that I'm sorry
the purpose of this fight really is to
do the following allow us to learn more
about the blade Ichigo Wheels it helps
to give us an idea of how much more
space there is for Ichigo to grow in the
story and of course to introduce two new
characters however each go while he at
first seemed to be having difficulty
with renji one of the two Soul Reapers
he picks himself up and suddenly a
torrent of spirit energy begins to flow
from him he's Never Felt This Good
before he has renji on the back foot he
doesn't feel pain anymore he's thinking
he has the power to save rookie and out
this is it all he has to do is deal the
finishing blowout
yeah he's pretty scary actually so look
things aren't good for Captain
strawberry right now he's about to die
arukia gave herself up and begged for
his life her brother has taken away from
Ichigo rukia's Soul Reaper powers and
all of his Spirit energy so now even if
he does survive it'll be inconsequential
or so he thinks to tell you the truth
though I thought this was a really
interesting ending to this battle and
has carried out in such a way that you
can tell exactly what Ichigo was feeling
can't talk can't move once again just
like he was when his mom died he was
spared letting a bloody mess on the
ground or the one he cared about went to
her death thankfully however Mr kisske
finds him just in time and manages to
save both he and Urdu from a painful
death but what's more is this lovely hat
wearing individual can provide Ichigo a
way of getting to the soul Society under
a specific condition that Ichigo allow
him to train him for the next 10 days
then and only then would Ichigo have the
power to save Rukia so you know what
that means training Arc time
foreign
I do want to take note of here however
is that in the prior section where uriu
and Ichigo were going all Bromance
against the giant Kaiju Hollow Mr kiske
made a point of stopping urukia from
interfering in the action which on its
own wouldn't be necessarily a big deal
he is interested in watching Ichigo and
this was an important learning
opportunity for him what I thought
however was a big deal was what he said
to Rukia concerning this decision to
stop her saying that and I quote it was
important for both her and he that
Ichigo did this alone that's interesting
given where Rukia finds herself right
now on death row I wonder if this remark
was speaking about her current situation
she's in with Seoul society that she
needs Ichigo to experience this as a
growing exercise or she needs those in
the soul Society to hear of this event
in order for her to have any hope of
surviving the death penalty that's
looming ahead of her but who cares about
that it's summer vacation I do however
like this little Recon group we have
forming here between the four main
players Ichigo oruhime Chad and uriu I
love all of their designs and I'm very
excited to see what ichigo's training
entails I'm a big fan of trainiarcs and
so first things first lesson one he
needs to restore his Spirit energy
something called his hakusui and its
booster the sakeetsu well they need a
jump start so his first step is to learn
how to control his kompaku body to do
that he is tasked with this little girl
it shouldn't be too difficult
oh she's awesome he manages to survive
and therefore oddly enough passes
apparently he just needed to survive one
blow she does have the power of a soul
Reaper after all and in the process he
was able to learn to breathe better so
baby steps good stuff on to lesson
number two this one is a lot more
serious and substantially more difficult
than getting decked in the face by a
preschool ichigo's chain gets severed
and if you look back into the story
that's a bad thing because now it's only
a matter of time before he becomes a
hollow to avoid that happening he needs
to unlock his soul Reaper powers and to
do that he needs to climb out of this
massive pit without the use of his arms
apparently and oh yeah he has three days
three days later he's screwed this looks
really awesome in the manga and what
follows I thought was a really cool
scene in ichigo's mind with his blade I
guess surging out of the pit below he
emerges almost an entirely different
looking character with an
extraordinarily cool design it almost
looks like it's part Hollow like he's
channeling that regret and lost into
some something that can enact meaningful
change in the story like he's co-opted a
part of himself that could become a
monster into something that can if
focused save and protect someone he
cares deeply for and so finally now that
he's passed the first two lessons he's
on to the third and final challenge
knock off Mr kusuke's Hat I really liked
all of these training challenges they
were a lot of fun and much like the rest
of them this too had its fair share of
more badass moments that I fondly
remembered as I'm writing this I love
that the sword itself is a character of
some description and obviously the way
that which chitekubo depicts this is
Stellar across the board but honestly
there's a short section right before
they all head away to the soul society
that I very much connected following
their training Chad Ichigo oruhime and
the rest of their classmates all decide
to hang out for a day and it's moments
like these that remind us of what
they're all there fighting for Quiet
Moments where they can all just live
together in peace happily and Rukia she
should be there too and in the middle of
the night the following morning right
before Ichigo leaves not knowing if
you'll ever return again is father of
all people has a parting gift for him he
Talisman ichigo's mother gave to him
long ago apart from this being a nice
and sentimental gesture I'm going to
predict that the reason Ichigo and his
sisters are all to varying degrees
spiritually sensitive is because their
mother was very spiritually sensitive
and that the Talisman she gave to her
husband is something that's designed to
protect people that she cares about it's
just a hunch but I think that would be
pretty cool if it's true in other words
I'm kind of waiting for that gift to
make the save on him at some point later
in time following that Ichigo Orihime
Chad and uriu step into the portal armed
with new capabilities not knowing if
they'll ever return again needless to
say I am very excited to see where this
goes
as many of you are no doubt aware this
review has been overwhelmingly positive
outside of the first chapter I thought
this Arc really went from strength to
strength culminating on a point in the
story that begs us to keep going and I
honestly can't wait to do just that next
week however right now I'd like to close
with this earlier this week two of my
friends asked me how I felt about the
series as I was reading it I replied
that I was loving my time with the manga
and that it was a totally different
experience than that which I had with
the anime almost 10 years ago both of my
friends they responded the same way the
response was that they were relieved now
obviously a person can feel this way for
a number of reasons but personally I
thought it was unfortunate that relief
was the dominant emotion felt during
this particular outcome not that I
necessarily blame either of them for
feeling this way bleach has
unfortunately become a very difficult
place to exist within online for anyone
looking to share an opinion that might
not match up with the status quo
certainly it's nice that I'm enjoying
myself but the idea that had I had a
negative experience it might have
otherwise brought about the opposite of
relief for these people doesn't really
sit right with me and this is all to say
that for one reason or another bleach
within the online circles I've seen has
become a very negative Place indeed so I
thought I'd share a happier story in
2001 Tite Kubo and bleach were both
rejected by Shonen Jump ultimately
deciding that they did not wish to pick
up bleach for serialization so how did
he get that second chance well Akira
Toriyama prominent inspiration of One
Piece Naruto and indeed bleach helped
him by putting in a good word and
honestly I think there's a lot that one
could glean from that very kind gesture
at the moment the current discourse
concerning bleach is that a vitriol for
those that show any distaste towards
that very material at least by a sizable
portion of the active online fanbase
some of these people think that by
acting this way they are in some way
righteously fighting for the respect the
story that they love deserves however
this I think could not be first further
from the truth in response to Kubo
getting rejected by Shonen Jump Akira
Toriyama someone whose opinion carried a
lot of weight within that very company
didn't choose to denigrate or insult the
staff at jumped for their decision but
instead decided to sing the Praises of
the writer and artist he believed in
fighting their subjective negative
experiences with his own positive words
and actions bleach so far has been a
terrific story that I'm thrilled I
decided to pick up and give another shot
to however even I will admit that had
this not been my job had I just returned
from school or work one day and had the
exchanges I've had with some folks in
this community concerning bleach I would
have been massively discouraged to ever
give this wonderful series another look
and so if there's anything I hope I
manage to effectively communicate in
this video or indeed this series is that
we ought to focus more on what we love
about this series rather than demonize
those that disagree with us because if
Toriyama on that day in the Shonen Jump
offices took a different more aggressive
approach we might not have gotten bleach
at all building up people wins over
Minds tearing others down will only
leave more negativity and I don't think
Tite Kubo or a story like bleach
deserves that thanks for watching